hey everybody and welcome back and today
we're continuing the series of where I
go over every Titan in titanfall 2 I
explained you their weapons personal
gadgets encounters and the you in the
comments below tell me if they are worth
playing or not today's episode we're
going to be talking about is ion ion is
a Titan class that is based around the
Atlas chassis design laser focused ion
is all about power with a central energy
system that fuels all of its offensive
and defensive abilities I am is
definitely an effective and tactical
force in the game for ion for ions
gadgets he has one called the splitter
rifle which is an automat an automatic
energy rifle which has an alternative
fire that has a strong split shot but
waste energy just like every other Titan
ion has four abilities which are the
laser shot which is a shoulder-mounted
laser the vortex shield which blocks and
returns incoming fire the laser trip
wire triggered enemy expire a triggered
explosive minds in the laser core which
is a heavy chested mounted laser cannon
now for ions personal kit he has the
entangled energy which is a splitter
rifle that crit hits restore energy the
zero-point tripwire where turbo our
deployment costs no energy vortex
amplifier which vortex shield returned
damage output is at thirty-five percent
instead of 20 the grand cannon is the
laser core last longer and the
refraction lens is where the splitter
rifles splits five ways instead of three
now four counters ion is more of the
average Titan so he really can't do much
damage and there's not much that
counters them so he really has to rely
on the laser shot to do most of his
damage the trip wire is absolutely
useless in my opinion because everyone
always shoots it and it's a waste of
energy where you could be putting into
your shield the only problem with ion is
that Legion is the biggest problem he
has because of his huge minigun he can
chew through your shield really quick
and drain the energy on your shield
making you
defenseless to keep an eye out for him
other than that there's really no other
counters so after giving you all of his
counters his weapons and his personal
gadgets I want all of you in the
comments below to tell me whether he is
a useful Titan enough for you to use in
titanfall 2 i'm very curious to hear
your answers other than that guys
that'll be it for this video like the
video if you enjoyed enjoyed comment
like i said before if you would like to
use ion or not in game after me telling
you and if you want to see more Titan
vol 2 videos then subscribe for more and
peace out guys